okay so episode one of moonlight is now
out on disney plus and the marvel mcu
show has a lot to unpack from it filled
with easter eggs and hidden details we
follow things from the perspective of
mark spect well we'll get into it
steven
the way we're tackling the story we
learn about stephen and then learn about
mark what's wrong with you mark
why did you call me mark and they're the
same person okay so if you have
absolutely no idea who moonlight is then
the next part of the video is for you
first introduced in werewolf by knight
32 moon knight or rather mark specter
was a hero that was often compared to
batman but marvel have done a great job
of separating the two born the son of a
jewish rabbi mark thought his father was
a coward because he fled europe during
the second world war in order to escape
the holocaust mark wanted to make
himself strong and thus he trained as a
boxer before he joined the army mark
ended up as a mercenary and during a
mission to egypt he was betrayed by a
man known as raul bushman who left him
at death store mark was carried before
the shrine of konshu and in exchange for
getting his life back he promised to
become the gods avatar on earth mark
returned to america and he became a
vigilante equipped with moonerangs
grappling hooks a cape a jet a moon cave
and a mansion but he's not batman yet
he's not batman now mark adopted several
personalities including stephen grant a
playboy millionaire and also jake
lockley a cab driver who had his ear
close to the street now mark is pretty
much missing from this first episode but
we do get things from the perspective of
stephen who has been changed up a lot
from the comics rather than being a rich
playboy he's now a museum staff member
that has trouble sleeping we know from
the trailers that both mark and stephen
are going to be going back and forth in
mirrors and the first episode is laced
with the idea of reflections throughout
the first comes when mark goes to work
and he walks through a puddle later on
when he pulls his heart out to your mime
we see a puddle is used once more they
do an amazing shot in this moment where
you think you're looking into the puddle
on the bottom but it's actually the top
steven also wakes up after his nightmare
and we get a shot of him inside of what
appears to be a pyramid with two
reflections on the right and left this
could represent mark and jake and this
is potentially referenced later on when
he's in the museum at night he walks
past the glass and we see two
reflections remain behind potentially
symbolizing the both of them now this is
mirrored on top of another mirror when
he's getting ready for his date and we
see that he has three panes of glass to
reflect his three personas there's also
the elevator scene and he needs to stop
being a smooth criminal put on that
white suit and come to grips with a man
in the mirror like michael jackson god
damn
now as he leaves the bus we get one in
the window and we know from the trailers
that he'll have a transformation in a
shot that looks similar to this the
episode of course culminates in a
bathroom filled with mirrors and we can
see that the back one is smashed which
could be a metaphor for mark breaking
out from behind them there's pretty much
no superpowers used in this entire first
episode and i absolutely love that they
instead tease us with the mystery of
what's going on with steven marvel shows
are often criticized for trying to get
us to come back every week with hints
towards a big villain and they even
removed scenes of kingpin from hawkeye
so that we talk on social media about
who the big bad is way better
storytelling to do this way and i think
most of the pieces end up on the board
come the end of the first entry now
before we get into the breakdown of the
episode we'd really appreciate you to be
the hero that this video needs so hit
that thumbs up button you punk and don't
forget to subscribe as we'll be going
over the series every single week in
case you're new here this is the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul aka poon
knight now let's get into the video
okay so episode 1 opens from the
perspective of arthur harrow and we hear
this song every grain of sand by bob
dylan
grains of sand are of course plentiful
out in egypt but beyond that the song
has a meaning that ties into this scene
according to bob's brother he recorded
this after becoming a born-again
christian and it takes us on a journey
of spirituality grains of sand are of
course plenty full out in egypt yeah
make sure you stay subscribed for
amazing facts like that
anyway harrow in the comics was a mad
scientist that carried out human
experiments during the second world war
he was given funding to continue the
easter the latter part of the 20th
century and moonlight ended up having to
put a stop to them where the show
differs is that it turns harrow into a
cult leader who's very much the hand of
the egyptian god known as amit ethan
hawk has stated that harrow is a david
koresh type figure who in real life said
he was the final prophet koresh created
a cult that ended up having a shootout
with the fbi and atf in an event that
was known as the waco siege it's clear
harrow is willing to carry out acts of
violence and at one point we see him
sending his soldiers after stephen in
order to gain a magical golden scarab
now as mentioned earlier this number two
of the gods is working for omit the
crocodile headed one harrow has a cane
with a creature's head on it and also a
tattoo that moves whilst judging souls
there's even a hint towards this when
steven is packing stuff for the gift
shop and we see him pick up a box with
the god's head inside of it later on
when he walks through the museum at
night we can also catch a crocodile
model hinting towards this moonaid has
had several face-offs against ahmed and
in the comics they even masqueraded as a
psychiatrist named dr emmett this was
during the jeff lemire run in which mark
was held prisoner at a hospital for the
mentally ill which may end up popping up
in the show we have had shots in the
trailer where he appears to be in one
and the book itself was very much about
mark learning to embrace the other sides
of his personality in addition to this
emmett also had orderlies that were
secretly jackals and they chased mark
throughout the hospital much like how
stephen is chased by one at the end of
the episode harrow is extremely
dedicated to the god and the guys in
denial if he doesn't want to see me bust
out these egyptian puns now we even see
him smashing glass at one point and
placing the shards in his sandals and
because of this every single step he
takes is extremely painful this
religious penance explains why he needs
a cane with him at all times and it
might hint towards his violent past that
we could learn about in the series
typically a religious penance is carried
out in regards to make up for sins
committed and these acts can range from
saying things like hail mary all the way
up to allowing rattlesnakes to bite you
depending on what you follow harrow
weirdly dips his finger in the water and
rubs it around the glass in order to
make a noise and this might be seen as
some form of baptism or something i
don't know but the guy just seems very
dedicated now from here we go to the
marvel studios logo which has had a
slight update xiangji was dropped in for
hawkeye and i believe that we now have
an added shot of doctor strange in
infinity war as the character is taking
on a more prominent role in the mcu
resource of the eternals and the song
you can hear in the background is a man
without love by engelbert humperdinck
this is clearly about steven who's
completely alone and he doesn't even
wake up to a notification saying the new
heavy spoilers video is out shabow
oh [ __ ] here we go again
now the idea of him waking up is also
mirrored in the lyrics and this is
reflected later on in the dream sequence
in which we get whams wake me up before
you go go
we see stephen believes that he suffers
from a sleeping disorder that means he
wanders off in the night but this is
later revealed to be did or dissociative
identity disorder i believe that stephen
remains in control when he's awake
because he's making a conscious effort
to stay that way however when he goes to
sleep mark takes over and he's able to
become moon knight this is hinata in the
rem or rapid eye movement which
typically takes place during sleep and
it actually shows the handoff between
mark and steven later on steven misses
an entire day and i think we might even
get the blanks in this episode filled in
later down the line now stephen changed
himself to the bed and also places duct
tape on the door in order to see if it's
been opened or not we later catch him
attempting to do a rubik's cube and in
this opening shot we can actually see
one completed beside his bed he's kind
of struggling with the one later on so
i'd love it if we found out that mark
was actually the one who did this
rubik's cubes are of course made up with
many sides that are all different shades
however they can come together in order
to create a hole i think it would be
amazing if we watched steven slowly
solve this throughout the series and it
would be some great symbolism if he
completed it come the end of episode 6.
him wearing white and lying in the
sheets might also be a nod to the lumia
run in which he spent a lot of time in
the hospital bed and at one point he
even ended up making a cape and mask out
of a pillow case and sheet the sand
around his bed could also be a nod to
the ritual putting a circle of salt
around something in order to protect
against evil forces now steven can't
remember his dreams or what happens at
night and this idea of memory is
reflected in his goldfish which are
known for having bad memories see kids
learn something new every day best
easter eggs ever now steven leaves a
voice note for his mother who apparently
has sent him out a postcard probably a
lot of crap and it's likely someone from
his past who he's constantly ringing
whoever it is sends him lots of
postcards of egyptian landscapes and
these are reflected in the fish tank
which too has them in but you know mark
definitely bought them as steven signs
off the call by saying i'll try again
tomorrow latest gators so yeah
alligators and crocodiles are the new
mephisto
although he should be fully rested up
steven falls asleep on the bus because
he's exhausted and this adds a lot of
weight to mark taking over at night
inside the museum he gets chatting to a
kid and they ask and did it suck for you
getting rejected from the field of reads
this very much reflects moonlight who is
saved from death by konchu and over the
years the goddess resurrected him
countless times it's even possible that
when he wakes up in the field later on
that this just happened after he died
and this conversation has a lot going on
with it stephen also talks about how the
egyptians believe that a person's heart
was weighed in the afterlife to see if
they'd been good or not this is very
much what harrow does later on and the
tattoos on his arms even have scales on
them to hammer this idea home it's at
this point that we're introduced to his
boss donna and every time i order a
donna i get called boss bit of a kebab
shop joke for you there anyway she gives
him some boxes to carry including a
scarab that looks a lot like the golden
one we get later on we know from the
trailer that the wings gonna open up and
as i've been saying it's all connected i
love this little bit here where he
reassures himself that he's stephen and
he taps on his name badge in order to
correct donna he's managed to bag a date
that he doesn't even remember booking
and this was clearly carried out by mark
because it's at a steak house and
steven's a vegan when he learns he's
missed an entire day he ends up breaking
this and he orders a steak we later
learn that mark also got a new goldfish
and i'm glad that he's got his
priorities in order now donna gets him
to put away some gift shop goodies and
these include hippos that are based on
the fertility goddess as well as mummies
in the jeff lemire run when attempting
to escape the psychiatric hospital
market mummy said on him and with us
going to egypt i can't see them popping
up and next sunnah moon now steven talks
about of the aniad the what the aniad
you know like the super group of
egyptian gods you know you've got horus
osiris tefnut shoes
who will probably be showing up at some
point they've been laced throughout the
comics and have often battled for mark's
soul later on he reads a book that
discusses the rift between god and man
that exists with them and the avatars
are very much used as their playthings
mark talks about how the museum poster
for them is missing gods and konju is
likely amongst them as he exits we hear
the flute from the song kashura kashura
which was sampled by timberland for
jay-z's song big pimpin
night jb
nice guy
guy got in a lot of trouble as he didn't
get the rights to it and it timber
landed him in hot water thank you i'm
here all week now to add to the
confusion the security guard calls him
scotty on the way out and to make things
even worse the outside of the museum
isn't even the one that we find steven
inside of filmed inside the british
museum he ends up outside the national
gallery at trafalgar square this may be
the throws for a loop when watching it
but it could also be because the museum
is going to be used at the illuminati
base in doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness as steven talks to a mime
about how if he doesn't tie himself down
he can wake up anywhere and this is
somewhat shown in his dream that we'll
talk about in just a bit this mime could
end up being crawly an informant who
helped jake lock the out with
information in the comics stephen is
pouring his heart out to him and being a
mime would allow him to blend into
places without people racing their god
crawley also appeared in the lumiere run
and mark had to win a soul back from
anubis by rescuing his wife's soul a
couple asked to take a photo with the
mime but that's a bit pointless because
everyone looks like a mime in a photo
now i love how steven talks about how
his body is just trying to hit his 10
000 step goal and anyone who's tracked
their fitness knows all about those 11
pm walks to get that notification also
there's a shop sign that says oscar like
oscar isaacs look i didn't say they'd be
good easter eggs now that night stephen
wakes up and he encounters arthur harrow
i believe this is in germany do the
architecture that looks like noise
weinstein castle completely butchered
that now this actually inspired he who
remains home in loki episode six and the
piece is quickly broken when harrow's
guards start firing at him stephen is
told by conshu to surrender his body to
mark and he also discovers the golden
scarab in his pocket we don't know what
happens to this but we do know from the
secret agent tv spot that it eventually
ends up in a lockup that mark has set up
scarabs are a symbol of raw and they're
also thought to bring regeneration and
immortality potentially explaining why
he wakes up here now we also don't see
what happens to make steven wake up with
a broken jaw but it is possible that he
went over the cliff like what we saw in
the trailers i did say in one of my
theory videos that i thought he might
have been saved by the snap but i don't
think that happened at all now but i at
least i didn't say there was a doctor
doom easter egg because of a cupcake box
i know it was you i know it was you
peddling that theory and i'll never
forget now i love it if we saw the
blanks that we get in these moments
filled in in future episodes as there's
a lot of scenes where stephen blacks out
and we see the destruction left in the
wake of mark's arrival it would be so
cool to get flashes of this i think but
we do get harrow's first interaction
with steven happen in these moments
lovely bit of costume design as we have
stephen wearing a white hoodie that he
props up and moon knight of course wears
a white hood it's not too long before
harrow arrives and we see that his
followers reach out to touch him much in
the same way that the christians did to
jesus he says he wants to bring heaven
to earth and ooh baby do you know what
it's worth ooh heaven is a place on
earth now he weighs two people's souls
and these are in the promise of serving
ahmed even before she wakes up now i
think these two people were chosen to
show that harrow is just cherry-picking
people to be his soldiers he ends up
accepting the young guy as a good person
when everyone knows we all have access
to the internet and there's no way that
anyone under the age of 50 hasn't looked
at some bad stuff whether the old woman
ends up dying and with ahmed being a
cell devara she could be feasting on
good people in order to power herself up
makes way more sense that good souls
would be more worthy and she collapses
and gets carried off the weird thing
about this is that stephen is talking to
harold like he's in the present even
though this clearly happens in the past
and just try getting your head around
how dreams change things in the past if
at all harrow also recognizes him and
calls him the mercenary which is what
mark specter was in the comics unable to
hand the scarab over stephen ends up
blacking out and mark takes over to do
what i'm gonna do to people that don't
like the video he escapes in a cupcake
van which leads to a high-speed chase
that mark takes over during when things
get rough stephen at one point even says
i don't even have my driver's license
and i'd love it if we learned that he
can't drive but mark can there's also a
lorry carrying tree trunks and i swear i
think you're one of these every time i
go on a motorway final destination 2 has
me up for life now there's a nice little
seven punch line here as mark causes the
lorry to crash he goes further down the
hill almost gets caught and is then
saved by the trees these hit him as well
possibly linking to the shot of him
going over the cliff and he then wakes
up steven makes a mistake and he misses
the stake date and i also forgot to
mention he's got a phone with
hieroglyphics on it that look like the
ones that appear in the bathroom later
on anyway mark returns back to his
apartment and he seems to be talking to
his mother again this time it appears
that she's responding but i think she's
just like my parents you know they're
not there now i will be here for you and
everyone loves a giveaway so i'm happy
to announce that we've teamed up with
noble chairs in overclockers uk to give
away an amazing hero chair to one of our
viewers whoever wins this can choose
between an iron man or spider-man 1 and
we're gonna announce the winner of the
competition on the next video all you
have to do is drop a comment below and
i'll scroll through them on tuesday
night and pick one at random
unfortunately it's only available to
people in the uk and eu but if you're in
the rest of the world hang around until
the end of the video for another
giveaway that we're doing now back
inside his home he discovers a phone and
keys to what i'm guessing is the locker
from the secret agent tv spot the phone
is inside a pyramid and it's a motorola
razer which i used to have kind of
showing its age now inside the phone are
several missed calls including one from
duchamp which is a character known as
frenchie that's an imoonite layla seems
to be a completely new creation though
she could be based on leyla o'toole who
comes from the comics this might also be
an amalgamation of her and marlene from
the source material who is a love
interest for mark leyla doesn't
understand why he's changed his accent
and upon hearing the name mark he gets a
specter of the character who talks to
him in a mirror he flees to a lift and
sees a vision of konshu and a fake out
that reveals it's actually an old lady
konchu can possess people so potentially
he used this old woman to hold the doors
open so that he could appear in the lift
we could instantly to the next day
unaware of what mark has been up to but
see the guard following him as he
travels on the bus harrow also stalks
him too and in the museum the security
guard otterbein someone who stopped him
but he didn't like otter you get it
because he's watching an otter video
anyway harrow shows he's got people
everywhere and it leaves stephen in a
harrowing situation i'm sorry how about
how bad these are getting now he
initially comes to stephen as a friend
and explains that ahmed could have
stopped several atrocities if she'd been
on earth he ends up weighing steven's
soul but due to the several
personalities within him he can't get a
read on him and therefore can't judge
him we discover that omer can see all
that someone will do and maybe she
killed that old woman because she farted
in the left or something nahara also
explains that ahmed was betrayed by her
own avatar and we could potentially meet
the agent that turned on her arthur is
now the person she uses and after
stephen gets away arthur sends in the
hounds now i absolutely love how tense
these scenes are just seeing random
members of the public step out of the
crowd and realizing that they're his
forces is great and there's so many cool
things that they can do with this we
also see the perspective of the jackal
outside the art gallery and this chases
steven throughout the exhibits the
jackal is also likely a death jackal
which are often referred to as the god
dogs of the dead the series very much
turns into an almost horror monster
movie thing and you can catch it moving
behind mark appearing in the reflections
of glass and it runs after him forcing
stephen into a bathroom after talking to
mark he finally hands over the body
willingly and it leads to the money shot
that was shown in all the trailers it's
a brilliant way to end the episode and
these hits are heard around the world
like well smith and chris rock i'm
guessing that next time we'll watch the
beast chase moonlight through the london
sky as this was heavily shown in tv
spots or we could end up getting more of
the jackals appear later on but that's
my theory now either way this was a
fantastic first episode and out of all
the mcu shows so far this was my
favorite one i love the whole god
aesthetic that they have going on and i
think it was brilliant to really hold
off the hero shot until the last second
of the show kept me interested
throughout and i also think it's super
smart to show things through the eyes of
stephen rather than having mark's origin
story play out in chronological order
the mystery that surrounds the show
makes it really enthralling to watch and
can we agree that this is up there as
being one of the best marvel costumes
ever made you better agree otherwise
you're blocked now i can't wait to see
how crazy oscar isaacs gets with it and
this was a very solid way to kickstart
the season moon knight is the best dc
film since harry potter and the revenge
of the jedi and it's going to be a blast
covering this series week to week you
better bloody join me i swear god
otherwise i'm kicking off mate and in
the meantime let me know your thoughts
on the premiere we are in a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of spider-man nowaday home on the 15th
of april and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now serve that
to you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of andrew garfield's return in
spiderman no way home in which we talk
about why it was iconic and all the
things that kind of factored into that
if not then thanks for sitting through
the video i'll see you on the next one
you take care of yourself and i love you
you have a good week peace